[Musik]
heute werden 209 junge menschen
angelockt die ein persönliches
versprechen auf die republik österreich
und auf die demokratie abgeben
unser bundesheer die strategische
reserve im land das hat man nicht zu
letzteren zahlreichen partner einsetzen
ganz deutlich gesehen aber auch bei den
katastrophen einsetzen dass es nach
regen schneefällen der vergangenen jahre
[Musik]
eine angelobung das ist ohne zweifel ein
bewegender moment vor allem auch deshalb
weil sie mit ihrem gelöbnis
verantwortung übernehmen verantwortung
für sich selbst für ihre kameraden für
die sicherheit unserer republik
österreich
mir ist bewusst dass sie das für sie
alle eine neue lebenssituation auch ist
denn sie haben ihre gewohnte umgebung
sie haben ihre gewohnte arbeitsstätte
verlassen um für ein halbes jahr den
dienst mit der waffe zu versehen
dafür möchte ich danke sagen dafür
möchte ich ihnen danke sagen dass sie
diese wahl getroffen haben um ihren teil
zur sicherheit österreichs und seiner
bewohner zu leisten
die basis unseres bundesheeres das sind
sie das sind die grundwehrdiener ohne
grundwehrdiener gebe es keine karte
soldaten ohne grundwehrdiener gibt es
keine miliz ich bedanke mich für ihre
einsatzbereitschaft und die bereitschaft
zu dienen
unsere heimat zu schützen unsere staat
österreich zu schützen unsere
bevölkerung unserer demokratie unserer
neutralität
es lebe das österreichische bundesheer
es lebe die republik österreich